hey guys how's it going it's Justine and
today we are back with another iPhone 10
video I know what you're saying Justine
it's been at least two or three days
since you've last posted a video about
your iPhone we know we get it you've got
one but guess what else I've got today
I've got some friends we have got the
Samsung Note 8 and the Google pixel two
and over here we've got the Sony rx100
mark 5 this is my absolute favorite
vlogging cameras it's gonna be really
fun to see how this kind of stands up to
these guys and to the iPhone 10 so let's
go Jenna just got the basketball court
or take some pictures or get some videos
or see what happens the first thing
we're gonna do is we're going to take
some photos so Jenna my lovely photo
assistant here my lovely photo assistant
you're coming basketball so I'm gonna
have you take some photos on all of
these and then the problem with what
we're shooting right now is when I did
the iPhone 10 camera test it was very
overcast which actually was pretty great
for shooting on this camera right here
this big one hello hi Nick all right hi
the first on the phone cameras that
proves to be a little bit more difficult
yeah but watch this you think I could
make it no no no this you didn't even
hit the backboard take a normal picture
and also take a portrait mode picture on
all of them yes
first up we have some photos from the
iPhone 10 with the rear camera this is
the iPhone 10 rear portrait this is an
example with the blur on blur off and
back with the blur on again and here
you've got them all three side by side
with a portrait the normal photo and
blur on moving on here we've got the
note 8 for your camera and then moving
on to the note 8 live focus here they
are side by side with the normal and the
live focus right next to each other
instead of calling the portrait mode
Samsung is calling it the live focus
here's those same shots using the pixel
2 and here we have the pixel 2 rear
portrait as you can see it did a really
great job blurring out the background
side-by-side normal verse portraits and
normal verse portrait yet again throwing
in that Sony rx100 point-and-shoot here
we have those two shots
back-to-back it's all relative right now
we're trying to do an action shot test
and Jenna is trying to press the button
on all of these cameras at the same time
so if you dip the same shot it's not
going so well we're trying
looking at this test after the facts you
know I had really great intentions but I
feel like it wasn't executed properly
all of these phones did a pretty great
job at these action shots I didn't
really spot much motion blur but of
course trying to get all of these shots
to match up properly proved to be a
little bit difficult
[Music]
I was
so right now we're gonna be testing out
the front-facing camera I'm gonna be
taking some shots and I love the pixel
front facing portrait mode it does a
really great job now let me see the
front facing on the iPhone 10 pixel -
and the note 8 which ones do you guys
think looks the best I did leave out the
rx100 but here it is I felt like the
phones did such a really great job that
it was kind of hard to throw in this
point-and-shoot camera especially since
I feel like the phones did a much better
job than a Sony did but here it is for
reference
everything's reporting think I'm in
frame on all of these let's just maybe
move this this is I'm having fun I'm not
sure we are now recording with all four
cameras the first one that I have right
here this is the Sony rx100 this is the
iPhone 10 this here is the pixel 2 and
over here we've got the note H so let's
just walk around a little bit
spin hi Nick hi hello you're walking
around you get some different
perspectives here see what these lens
flares look like oh look at that can you
can you talk about those flares JJ
Abrams call me definitely you're
definitely gonna want to use these shots
in your next film so right now we're
testing out the slow-mo on all of the
phones and the rx100 we've got them all
120 frames a second so we're in tests up
the slow mode
we got and I'm gonna take a drought
let's do it she's taking it up
[Music]
this was such a fun test to do and I
honestly planned on posting this video
Wow like a few weeks ago but I ran into
some problems getting the slow-mo
footage off of the note 8 and the pixel
2 so here it is I hope that you guys
enjoy it I look forward to hearing your
feedback on which camera you liked the
best
I'll put a poll up here at the top on
YouTube and you guys can choose which
one was your favorite did you like the
pixel to the iPhone 10 the rx100 or the
note 8
[Music]
you